we've all heard of the term Dark Ages
that medieval period in which all
learning stops and everything became
terrible
it's a term attributed to Patrick who
likely to Renaissance thinkers thought
that the Middle Ages were a period of
darkness in comparison to the Classical
period from before and the Renaissance
after so just to let you know the
definition of Dark Ages has changed
since the days of pet rock nowadays it's
a very specific term but be aware the
Dark Ages isn't synonymous with Middle
Ages it refers exclusively to Western
Europe in the couple of centuries
following the collapse of the Roman
Empire of course the question is how
true is the commonly held vision of this
period where the Dark Age is really that
dark and unenlightened well in a word no
in a sentence not really but also a
little bit of ending and where and where
you're talking about so Western Europe
had largely been united under the rule
of the Roman Empire and after its
collapse it was divided into competing
realms
there's obviously too many to speak of
in any sort of detail so we'll pick two
extremes and compared them the former
province of Italia and that of Britannia
whose experiences of the Dark Ages are
proof that they weren't quite as awful
as is often made out to be
so in Britannia after the Romans left
things went really well just kidding
they fell apart almost immediately
things like a coin based economy urban
living and literacy died out there
within a generation whereas in places
like the ostrogothic kingdom which
occupied the former province of italia
and then some very little changed and
whilst yes it did now have a germanic
ruler King Theodoric he swore fealty to
the Roman Emperor in the East the Senate
continued to meet in Rome in the Pope's
rights were respected although the
official Church of the Ostrogoths was
centered in Ravenna as for urban living
the number of people in towns and cities
had declined massively in most places
Rome's population had declined from
roughly a million people in the third
century to about 50,000 during the
ostrogothic period but what about the
peasantry how did life change for them
after Rome had gone well frankly not
very much most people were born lived
and died working as agricultural
laborers on the same farm as their
forebears had localized families were
also much more common and couldn't be
alleviated by a centralized Authority
meaning that local starvation was much
more common this largely went away in
ostrogothic Italy when it was conquered
in the 6th century by the eastern Roman
Empire now known as the Roman Empire
which undermines pet rocks notion of the
post Roman world being an unenlightened
one because the Romans never went away
the Dark Ages did see many intellectual
achievements though
monasteries like Lindisfarne and monk
worm of chero produced great historians
like
bead in the ostrogothic kingdom Boethius
wrote the consolation of philosophy
which is one of the most important
medieval texts ever written and in terms
of architecture buildings like
Theodoric's mausoleum a testament to the
fact that in the Dark Ages things
weren't as dark as they may seem I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching with extra thanks to my
patrons that you see on screen now and a
special thanks to James Bissonnette
izalco flash mark H party-boy Co David
archaeologist Rob Waterhouse Chris
wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan
onion duck David Silverman Paul Maggie
packs Kowski Winston K word vasily era
vedas christian check hey Anthony
Beckett Skye Chappell Adam Harvey and
Ike